what's going on guys this is Rob and I
know we're a few days late to this but
let's kind of let's talk about the Black
Adam trailer right your trailer
breakdown Easter eggs everything you
missed that kind of a thing which is
kind of interesting because I don't
really see a whole lot of people doing
this and to be honest with you guys I
think this speaks more to how people
view the DC landscape whereas is kind of
like I mean they're movies that exist
but at this point and I'm not gonna I
don't really want to tear down the DC
landscape and in truth I kind of have a
few ideas on how to redeem it on how to
like bring it back and make it this this
comic book movie landscape that should
be better than the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because the reality is it
should right it really really should
because everything that Marvel Comics
has done over the course of their entire
publication history is built on the work
that everything DC did right like all
the archetypes anti-hero superheroes
villains all that kind of stuff they're
all due to the work that DC did right
they all exist because of them so I
think at the moment what you have is
this situation where like a DC movie
comes out and like people will go see it
but in order for more Warner Brothers to
really kind of be elevated back to the
place they were when the hype was there
at the beginning of their Cinematic
Universe it really relies on Word of
Mouth we're past the point when a
trailer drops and everybody gets excited
and now is one of those things where
like the movie comes out and if like
people are non-stop talking about how
great it is like with the joker then
everybody goes and sees it but unless
it's something like that the movie just
won't do very well right which is kind
of disappointing but uh having said that
right so so one of the biggest things
about this trailer and it's kind of
interesting there wasn't really a whole
lot going on with it right it's just
like it's kind of an expanded version of
the teaser that we got and there's not
much in the way of of the overall film
itself and a lot of people are kind of
taking that as is sort of the the canary
in the coal mine right they're just like
okay this movie's just not going to have
much going for it it's going to be a
very thin plot it's not going to be very
interesting and that's going to be it
because nobody who's making these movies
is actually a fan of comics right or at
least the the people who are real
writing the screenplays and that kind of
stuff how much of that is accurate I
can't really speak to but the the
important thing here is is we kind of
get a continuation or a little more of
an expansion on what we've seen before
so the first thing is the Justice
Society of America now one of the big
questions that I've seen a lot of people
asking online is why do all the members
all the people in this movie appear so
weak well what I will say is to a degree
there's more than meets the eye to some
of them so most of the people in this
movie are very very weak Dr Fate is the
exception but it depends on how they do
Kent Nelson so here's the thing Ken
Nelson's ridiculously overpowered right
like this guy of course you guys know is
played by by Pierce Brosnan and for
those of you guys who are totally
unfamiliar right comic book noobs you've
never read a comic in your entire life
this is going to piss off Dr Fate fans
but they'll be okay until you know once
I make my point they'll understand or
they won't I don't care for those of you
guys who were totally unfamiliar with
with Dr Fate think of him as DC's
version of Doctor Strange now there are
big differences one in terms of like
comic publication History Dr Fate came
long before Doctor Strange like a few
decades before doctor strange and two
depending on what era of comics you're
talking about he's more powerful now
it's waxed and Wayne Right Doctor
Strange is far weaker than he used to be
at the height of Dr Strange's power oh I
would say he would have he would have
dwarfed the power of of Dr Fate but in
the modern era no he liked the he would
he would lose the Doctor Fate because Dr
Fate is just he's on that kind of next
level of power beyond what Stephen
Strange has but in a lot of ways they're
strikingly similar I don't know exactly
how they're going to do his powers in
the movie I don't really know what role
they're going to play the truth to tell
I'm more interested in Hawkman right uh
the the guy just basically played by
aldress Hodge I'm more interested in him
and the reason for that of course is uh
is people are largely suspecting and we
don't really know for certain but people
are suspecting this is Carter Hall and
if it is Carter Hall there's huge
potential here there's a lot that can be
done here now the Mythos of Hawkman and
Hawkgirl is actually really really
interesting and it changed recently so
and you know we'll focus more on like
what happened recently in comics as
opposed to focusing on the old stuff
because it doesn't really matter anymore
um just based on what we've seen with
the movie with like the origin of uh of
Black Adam in the sense that he was a
slave at one point and all that kind of
stuff they're basing his origin on the
new 52 and so for those of you guys who
don't know what that means in 2012 or
2011 DC rebooted their whole landscape
basically saying that nothing we wrote
before this matters if you've never read
a DC Comic once in your life that's fine
because this is all basically new right
so it's like DC is saying pretend we've
never published Comics before and read
forward from there the problem is there
were things they did with like Batman
and Green Lantern where you couldn't
ignore it you had to know about certain
things because of how the stories were
written so not totally clean but for the
case of Black Adam you never had to have
read a Black Adam comic in your entire
life you could go and pick up Shazam
which is really a backup feature in the
Justice League Comics
um and you could read the zero issue for
Black Adam right the villain story and
then you would basically know everything
you needed to know in order to
understand the accuracy of the care
character in the moment so they're going
with the new 52 right so that kind of
makes sense and so going on on that
newer information and moving forward
Carter Hall was cool because the idea
was that you had something called enth
metal which was like this this metal
that had what was it affect mystical
properties and it was actually a metal
that if I recall came from the dark
Multiverse uh which brings in even more
possibilities but basically the overall
gist of Hawkman is that he was kind of
cursed with this him and hawkerel so
that whenever they die they'll be reborn
in human form later on now while that
may seem dark it was actually a really
cool and honestly really romantic part
of their story because it basically
meant that no matter what happens from
the time that they would die in their
initial forms until really the ending of
the world they would always find each
other they would always be reborn and
they would always come back together
again and so it was a really really
sweet and a really romantic concept for
those those two characters having said
that Carter Hall was also a beast do not
misunderstand that romantic element
right this guy was like was not Leonardo
DiCaprio from from Titanic you know
where he's like painting French girls
naked that's not that's not what he was
doing right like this guy was a was a
huss like when it came down to a fight
hawkman's the guy you wanted in your
corner if you didn't have anybody else I
mean let's be honest I mean hawkman's
cool but I mean come on you know let's
if you have the choice between like
Batman Superman Shazam I don't know
Green Lantern you'd pick them yeah maybe
Aquaman but like if you didn't have
anybody else I mean yeah you know Hawk
man he's he's number one on the backup
list right so the guy was cool I mean
I'm not taking away from him I'm not
saying he sucks I feel like I'm digging
a bigger hole
I feel like I'm making it worse but but
in all seriousness for real and for True
hawkman's got it work counts right and
so uh the whole reason why him being
Carter Hall seems really really cool is
because it brings in the dark Multiverse
so for Carter Hall like his his desire
in order to understand instrumental the
properties of it and all that kind of
stuff it took him on a journey and what
he ended up discovering was the dark
Multiverse and he actually just ended up
becoming this super twisted and dark
version of himself but for those of you
guys who don't know what that means the
Multiverse as you know it in New Orleans
presumably will know about it in DC
Comics as you'll likely see it in
Flashpoint that'll be the point when we
find out whether or not the dark
Multiverse exists the Multiverse as you
see it is really only one side of the
equation it's a yen to a Yang and the
Yang would be the dark Multiverse
basically this Multiverse where
everything bad that can happen does
happen right like every possible
terrible scenario so like just focusing
on Batman for example there's stories
out there where Batman basically
strapped Barry Allen The Flash to the
hood of the Batmobile drove move into
the speed force and then basically came
out as an amalgamation of Batman and the
Flash calling himself red death and yes
he's every bit as awesome as you think
he is there is a version of Batman from
the dark Multiverse that it basically
taken over Cyborg and called himself
murder machine he was also really cool
like I mean like one they had amazing
names right like just the names were
cool the Batman who laughs he's the
coolest out of all of them the DC
overused and just killed interest for
his character but basically Batman in an
alternate reality in the dark Multiverse
killed the Joker or I'm sorry really The
Joker killed himself and when that
happened uh like the this kind of just
exceedingly potent and pure strain of
the Joker toxin that was literally
confined in the Joker's heart permeated
out and infected Batman and Bruce Wayne
basically turned into the Joker like it
was nuts the kind of stuff he did man
like what is it he uh he captured
Superboy and Superman and Lois Lane put
them in like a like a prison unit and
then exposed Superman and Superboy to
block Kryptonite which drove them insane
they tore Lois Lane apart then they
killed each other he killed the entirety
of the Justice League I mean it was nuts
it was it was just it was crazy the kind
of stuff he did it was all just super
dark and super Twisted but the fact
remains right like that's where the dark
Multiverse has to offer now do I think
definitively DC would go in that
direction no but Carter Hall's
exploration of it would be a great way
to eventually segue into it because
literally in the comics Carter Hall was
like I'm going to investigate you know
where where this Trail leads and then
was gone well I just vanished and you
never found out what happened to him
like Batman was hunting on the trail for
this guy and then eventually everything
with the dark Multiverse starts to go
nuts but that'd be a great way like if
they wanted to introduce the dark
Multiverse like you just have some
post-credits scene for Carter Hall where
like he's just been experimenting with
it or at least trying to track down his
own history understand it better or
whatever and then he just kind of goes
into some cave or travels through some
portal or goes to some location and just
vanishes and they never tell you like
you never get an answer in that
post-credits scene what happened to him
and then lo and behold you get
Flashpoint and you get this Glimpse or
something along those lines of the dark
Multiverse and like what happened to
Carter Hall and it's like okay what's
this dark Multiverse and you go from
there again that would take a lot of
planning uh it would take a lot of work
and you would really have to have it
fleshed out and as we know the DC
Cinematic Universe is the opposite of
planning anything out so uh so that's
that's kind of
that's kind of the issue you run into
but getting back into our trailer
breakdown right so you've got Noah
centineo's basically playing Atom
Smasher now for those of you guys who
don't know who this is this this is
going to blow your mind right Adam smash
I mean he's okay right basically he can
manipulate he can control his bodies uh
molecular structure to make himself
bigger and make himself stronger
whatever it doesn't really matter the
cool thing about this is that this guy
was originally part of a group called
the All-Star Squadron and then later
joined the Justice Society of America so
for those of you guys who don't know
All-Star Squadron was kind of cool right
it was really really cool so the way
this played out and this is kind of this
kind of speaks to the role of the JSA
and I don't really know exactly how
they're going to explain this in Black
Adam I'm kind of excited to find out to
be honest there's the old school way
that JSA used to exist where they were
in an alternate reality but we didn't
know until a story called uh the flash
of Two Worlds which established they
were in an alternate universe they
streamlined and cleared a lot of that up
in the 1990s when they brought the JSA
back after a story called uh called
crisis on infinite Earth basically the
post-crisis landscape which eliminated
the Multiverse so the idea behind this
the JSA as as it'll likely be in the
Black Adam film and the way it was the
easiest way to understand it in the
comics is that they were basically a
World War II superhero team that the JSA
the reason why their their members were
weaker is because they got their powers
from like artificial means now one of
the other reasons why they were weaker
is because the JSA as it was redone in
the 90s basically followed the form and
function of the JSA as it existed in
back in the 1940s when DC Comics was
originally printing their stories or
All-Star Comics was originally printing
their stories right characters back then
in the 1940s were nowhere near as
powerful as they would eventually become
in the 50s 60s 70s 80s going forward but
the thing about this is that with the
JSA operating during World War II they
were only one part of it that the JSA
was kind of like the Justice League of
the 1940s they were like the premier
team but you also had other teams around
there that were basically smaller one of
those was All-Star Squadron and the idea
was that there was a kind of uh I guess
a campaign that was launched called
equal x which was basically a superhero
draft and it asked any of those
superheroes which kind of defies the
nature of a giraffe right a draft is
like you're just brought in whether you
want to be there or not but it basically
asked that anybody out there who is a
superhero enlist in the military and so
those individuals who were capable but
weren't really JSA material became
All-Star Squadron material and then they
became material for for other people
Adam Smasher was one of those now again
he actually gained his powers from his
grandfather so it was one of those
things that was handed down generational
lines that's also one of the differences
between the Justice League of America
and the JSA is that when it came to
groups like All-Star Squadron JSA
members people like people like that a
lot of their powers were inherited right
so you had uh Johnny quick and you had
Jesse quick for example right that like
Johnny quick basically found out a way
to access the speed force by using a
mathematical proof and he could shout
that number and then basically become
Johnny quick kind of a weaker version of
The Flash that was passed down to Jesse
quick she learned the formula as well
and could do the exact same thing so
it's one of those things where more
often than not you saw Powers passing
through generational lines when you were
dealing with All-Star Squadron JSA
things like that more than you did with
the Justice League now that kind of
changed to a degree in the sense that
like Batman had no kids so he had Robins
Superman has his son Jonathan Kent
Wonder Woman doesn't have any kids
different things along those lines so
again it's kind of changing or at least
has changed in that way but at the end
of the day Adam Smasher is cool I think
he's going to bring a kind of uniqueness
to the movie that's not readily
available from the other superhero films
that we've seen and then you know
following that of course you've got
quintessa Swindle who's basically
playing Cyclone I mean she's okay she
can control the wind I mean I don't
really like pass over her because it's
like she doesn't matter she's just a
very simplified character but the cool
thing about this and I think this really
speaks more towards what will happen in
the movie regarding Black Adam uh more
than anything else is Osiris and Isis so
for those of you guys who don't know
Isis is being played by Sarah Shahi I
think is how you pronounce that I'm not
I'm not exactly sure how to pronounce
her name or the guy who's playing Osiris
so I apologize ahead of time if I
absolutely butcher these names the
reality is that Isis is kind of the love
interest of like Adam sort of insofar
that it's because of her the fact that
he falls in love with her that he ends
up not really becoming a hero but
becomes less of a villain and that's
something that we'll talk about you know
once we get to kind of a bonus thing
that I want to bring up which is a lot
of people criticizing the line from both
the teaser as well as seemingly this
trailer where Black Adam admits to
killing people so the thing about this
is that with her being somebody that
Black Adam wanted to protect what he did
is he gave her something called The
Amulet of Isis and what this does is
that when she says I am Isis she
basically becomes the Black Adam
counterpart right she becomes
essentially almost equal to him in power
now of course you've got Osiris who
essentially does the exact same thing he
says Black Adam and he becomes black
Adam's younger and less powerful
counterpart but the thing about this is
that the the character of Isis that's
what will really seem to hint at what's
going on with Black Adam because image
trailer he talks about like the loss of
his son he talks about being turned into
a slave different things like that and
so obviously the movie is going to focus
on this idea that like there's a big
hole in the heart of Black Adam and I
don't say that to like you know make a
joke about it I mean I think that's
really what it is like that aspect of
his life is missing and having gone
through all that turn him into a very
hard and a very bitter person the idea
of Isis and Osiris looks like it's going
to fix that that he's going to
essentially have a family so think of
what you saw in the shazam movie right
where like uh Billy Batson was a kid who
was like abandoned by his mom and left
in a foster home and he's got a big
grudge because he feels like he doesn't
have a family or anything like that and
then he shares his power with the rest
of the adopted kids and now they have
their own family that's basically what
you're going to see here with Black Adam
in reality outside of like the darker
more villainous aspect of it I don't
think you're really going to see a huge
difference between the Black Adam film
and the Shazam film and you really
shouldn't because they're very similar
in a lot of ways and in fact more
recently the Shazam storyline and the
Seven magic lands oh my God that story
was amazing I loved it I mean Shazam as
he's more recently been written in DC
Comics by Jeff Johns has absolutely been
designed more for a younger audience
right for kids who are between I would
say maybe like eight and like 12 years
old but it was a great story and like at
the end of it Black Adam becomes a good
guy and like joins the Shazam family
which was awesome I absolutely loved
that story it was just fun right just
just uh just a ripping good time but it
was it was absolutely great you know if
you want to read just a fun comic book
story read that one right like read
Shazam and the Seven magic lands it's
great you need to read the Shazam backup
feature in the Justice League first
which is not overly lengthy I think it's
a total of seven issues basically but
it's great right it's a really really
really fun story but that's kind of what
you're getting here right you're
basically getting this idea of Black
Adam kind of forming his own family it's
really going to be one of these things
where there were essentially because of
Isis black Adam's heart is just going to
become softer he's going to become a
gentler Kinder person and then
ultimately you know become more of a
hero now it doesn't necessarily mean
he's going to become a straight up good
guy and he doesn't need to be because
Black Adam never really has been so for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with the nature of his
character black Adam's very similar to
Black Panther in a lot of ways albeit
more willing to kill when it comes to
Black Panther he won't readily kill
people but the big similarity between
Black Panther and Black Adam is how
protective they are so when it comes to
Black Adam he rules a country called
conduct and let me tell you something
man like that guy if it like when you
think of black panther right like if you
only know Black Panther from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as much as I love
that movie it didn't really give you an
accurate comic book depiction of black
panther but like all the intelligence
that you saw that shuri had in the Black
Panther movie that's t'challa t'challa
is that smart he could do all that stuff
right like sure he's there and her role
in in the Black Panther Mythos is more
ceremonial than anything else until
do-more when she becomes the New Black
Panther and t'challa just becomes more
of the ceremonial person he's like the
ceremonial black panther but he doesn't
actually rule wakanda as king but he
will kill anybody like if if black
panther has to choose between letting
the world burn or protecting wakanda
he'll Protect wakanda by any means
necessary and he doesn't care what he
has to do in order to do it Black Adam
is the exact same way he is wildly
protective of his people in conduct and
and literally he'll kill anybody that
gets in the way like a really good
example of this is in the Injustice
Comics right when Superman basically
becomes this dictator for reasons that
we're 100 Justified and he ends up uh
essentially Conquering the world or
basically forcing the world to fix its
problems because the world didn't want
to there comes a point when like Shazam
and Wonder Woman show up on the doorstep
of conduct and and literally like Black
Adam is like I'm not siding with
Superman and if he comes here I will
kill him and he could to be honest with
you guys like black at him there's been
times Black Adam has beat the sh
H out of Superman it's it was it's been
hilarious but like there's there's a
Portland like they pin him down right
Shazam because the powers are a little
bit different in terms of how they work
in Shazam and Injustice right not
everybody's as powerful as they normally
are not everybody's as weak as they
normally are things kind of change but
the important thing here is that like
Wonder Woman and Shazam basically pinned
down Black Adam and Black Adam realizes
what's happening and like they
essentially know they're going to turn
him back into his human form and when
that happens he's gonna die because he's
exceedingly old right like he's
incredibly old he'll just immediately
like he'll just turn to dust right
because his body won't be able to handle
the strain of being that incredibly old
and so the result of this is that Wonder
Woman Like slaps him with the lasso of
Truth and it's just like what's your
name or something like that so that when
he says his name Black Adam he reverts
back to to his own human form but
there's a point in that like in that
moment and it's amazing when he begs
Billy Batson and he's like protect the
people of kandak do not let them come
under the reign of Superman he's that
protective so like literally it doesn't
really matter what it is if people roll
into conduct and start causing problems
Black Adam he'll kill them without Mercy
like he'll heal he'll do it without the
slightest bit of Mercy right it's just
he's a really really cool character so
that's why I say in the movie I don't
really see him becoming a tried and true
hero I see him basically becoming a guy
who is less of a dick than he was before
that's really what it would be uh and so
that kind of goes into this last little
thing that we were talking about where
people were criticizing black Adam's
line that like you know like like all
these guys don't kill people and he's
like you know I do because he does like
Adam does kill people because he's not
really a hero I mean you can make an
argument he's an anti-hero I guess but
Black Adam kind of stands alone outside
of like the traditional roles of like
Heroes anti-heroes he just does whatever
is good for the people of kandak that's
really it that's where his Allegiance is
his Allegiance is to his people and so
there's been times when like he works
with the heroes because the threat was
so extreme it would destroy essentially
Khan dock itself and there were times
when when he cited against the heroes
because the heroes themselves were a
threat to conduct so like that's where
his Allegiance is so he stands outside
of the traditional role of heroes and
villains so with that being said guys uh
again there wasn't really a whole lot to
go on when it came to this trailer I
mean there were some cool things you
know but at the end of the day it was
just kind of a trailer that exists and
didn't really give us a whole lot to
talk about and to be quite Frank didn't
really build up a lot of hype I'm still
gonna go see the movie I just wish they
had done a little bit more to make the
film more exciting but with that being
said at least by the trail I'm more
exciting with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end and I will
catch you all later
peace